advances in technology are changing the
way we understand brain activity in
diagnosing potentially deadly mental
health disorders suicide is one of the
leading causes of death in the United
States according to the CDC as part of
Mental Health Awareness Month Niki
batiste shows us how researchers are
using brain scans to spot harmful
thoughts Niki good morning good morning
Don good morning everyone we visited
Carnegie Mellon University to take a
look at research led by psychology
professor dr. Marcel just he spent
decades developing a sophisticated
system to try and read our minds and now
he's making a breakthrough into suicidal
thinking we found that there was there
were certain concepts that were altered
in people who thought about suicide and
our method was able to detect those
differences and analyze exactly what the
difference is consists of that method
begins with a sophisticated piece of
equipment a functional MRI with fMRI you
see a picture of the brains activities
so you're saying every thought idea and
our brain has its own specific pattern
yes
and what's really I think fascinating
and relatively new is the patterns are
similar across people unless you have
suicidal thoughts then they're altered
that's what psychiatric illnesses do
they change the way you think and this
method can I think identify those
changes these images show to people
thinking about the word death this one
has thought about suicide this one has
not the colors represent brain neurons
when you see dark blue that means very
little firing and the red is telling you
that you get activation related to self
thinking when they're thinking about
death but among people who have made an
attempt you see even more of this dark
red 34 people took part in his latest
study 17 of them never had suicidal
thoughts but the other 17 had and over
half of those 17 had even attempted
suicide in the past these
second-by-second snapshots show clear
differ
in the brain patterns when the
participants were asked to think about
different concepts like carefree praise
and death those snapshots were then
analyzed by this complex computer server
storing hundreds of thoughts by hundreds
of people with the power to search for
unique patterns we can tell whether
somebody's feeling anger or happiness or
sadness we can tell what number of
persons thinking we can tell what topic
a person is reading a paragraph about
doctor just method was 90 percent
accurate in determining who had past
suicidal thoughts and attempts how my
doctor just research changed the future
of suicide if we could understand the
neurobiology underlying the drive to
harm oneself then we would be able to
design better therapies aimed at
reducing that desire the treatments that
we have now don't work all that well dr.
Joshua Gordon director of the National
Institute of Mental Health thinks doctor
just worked could lead to more effective
treatment so potentially in ten years I
might go to the doctor's office
electrodes are put on my brain they will
be able to tell whether I have a mental
illness whether I'm suicidal possibly
it's slightly optimistic but not
impossible maybe twenty years the
National Institute of Mental Health
recently awarded dr. just and his team a
three point eight million dollar grant
to continue their research they have
already proven their method works to
identify autism spectrum disorder in the
future dr. just hopes to apply his
approach to other psychiatric disorders
like depression schizophrenia and
bipolar disorder such amazing work
they're doing this is brilliant tender
better understand the neurobiology of
the brain these causes that are in some
ways out of our control to find
treatment I think are so so important
that's that really exciting and woman
and that point is so interesting which
is to say that you know your brain is
doing things you can't think your way
out of right that it's why there is
wiring at play here which which would
help at least to understand the
condition you're in you know
understanding our brain neurons is so so
important to a possible treatment
and doctor just says he and his team are
about three years away from being able
to completely read our minds within
reasonable accuracy I asked him
yesterday if I'm thinking I want to win
the lottery when might you be able to
identify that thought in my mind he said
oh we can already do that think about
like if you were able to use that
neurobiology and those scans right
certain types of medications that you're
using whether they're working or not
whether exercise affects and change
whether the diet that you're engaged in
affects and you could see the changes
that would help us all find ways to
treat issues that we have yes
revolutionary work that they're doing
for sure thank you I like that because
last Niki